bah c'est pas mal coude je t'en remercie
dis moi tu avais une voix de femme
pourquoi tu as choisi un prénom est-il
alors j'ai pas le bois de forme je suis
désolé je ne vois pas ce que je suis un
homme donc j'ai une voix d'homme des
bois ça choisi un prénom de fille parce
que mon kit est accrocheur comme
chanteuse qui s'appelle victor si ce que
tu as fait rien ça c'est un prénom
féminin de 2,2 à gunther candidats ça
n'existe pas donc c'est mon prénom c'est
nous tout est rageant c'est un prénom
d'un chien un chat pour l'influencé
c'est un prénom de moi ce qu'est ce
qu'il faut faire quand il sera grand
quand je serai grande écoute j'ai
définitivement je pense que je resterai
petit vous avez dit d'abord on devient
moins fait tilt non non moi je resterai
appareils
ces programmes est comme ça ça me va on
n'ira plus je m'arroge sous les gens
mais c'est pas pour les mêmes raisons
ses pourboires pour être vrai mais non
merci